hello everyone and welcome to another
video now this is the Intel Ark A310
it's one of the cheapest new graphics
cards you can buy it's currently one of
if not the weakest card in the desktop
Arc lineup so my question today is
should you buy it this is the sparkle
elf version now Sparkle go way back I
think they used to be an Nvidia board
partner from the early 2000s up until I
want to say
2013 the last time I saw a sparkle card
was back when the GTX 700 series has
came out that's all changed now of
course this 75 watt card features 4 GB
of gddr6 memory and requires no external
power there is also a 50 W low profile
version which makes more sense for more
compact systems in the box we have the
card and nothing else who needs a driver
disc in 2024 anyway who even has a dis
Drive we've got three display port um
ports here and one HDM I the only place
I found this for sale in the UK is
Amazon where I paid
£20 in the US I've seen a310s for $99
though not necessarily this model as an
arc card it's best used in a system with
resizable bar support for Optimal
Performance so I've paired it with my I5
12400 f as well as 32 GB of 3200 MHz
ddr4 at the time of this video I'm using
Windows 10 Pro build
19045 let's get into some games so I
started off easy for the ark A310
Fallout 4 1080p with the medium preset
TAA for an average of 83 I did actually
start off with high but we actually saw
dips below 60 FPS quite frequently
especially in this area here Cambridge
which is quite intensive 64 FPS was the
1% low and the 0. 1% low was 28 I
expected Fallout 4 to do well though
especially at lower settings because it
is quite an old game though that's said
Arc cards can have a bit of trouble with
older titles Counter Strike to is up
next 1080p with a high preset and AA off
I'd probably recommend playing with a
low preset to maximize frame rates in a
competitive game like this but as a
graphics card Benchmark I thought we'd
see how high I can sort of push things
and it had no trouble with the high
preset 110 FPS with a 1% low of 69 nice
and a .1% low of 30 next up I tried The
Witcher 3 next gen 1080p with the lowest
settings here this one didn't do so well
especially at higher visual preset so we
were best off sticking to the lowest
settings albeit with FXAA we could have
enabled FSR as well to get that frame
rate over 60 but I felt as though this
was good enough 58 on average the 1% low
was 48 and the. 1% low was 23 the game
certainly picks up outside of busier
areas this is why I felt that the lowest
setting things was fine without any
extra help from upscaling but it's
entirely up to you of course now as you
may imagine Starfield is problematic for
this 4 GB entry level card 1080p with
the lowest settings and Native
resolution produced just 18 FPS pretty
unplayable if you ask me now in order to
try and improve things I enabled xess
and set it to Performance mode this
didn't help all that much 22 FPS was the
average the 1% low was 18 and the 0.1%
low was 16 so yeah it uh it made things
a little more consistent but I don't
really think 22 FPS is playable the only
thing left to do then aside from drop
the native resolution which didn't
really help uh was enable FSR 3 at 50%
res scale with frame generation FSR 3 on
its own frame gen off didn't make any
difference so I enabled frame gen for 38
FPS 29 was that 1% low and the .1% low
was 27 so it certainly bumped things up
a bit but frame generation doesn't feel
that great if you're not getting at
least 60 FPS don't get me wrong it
definitely felt better than playing at
22 FPS like we were just now but it's
not going to feel as smooth as a normal
38 FPS if you get what I mean Apex
Legends highest settings here all else
lowest tsaa set on for 109 FPS the 1%
low was 63 and the 0.1% figure was 52 so
for games like this Apex Legends and
csgo as we saw earlier those Esports
online games it's going to do pretty
well and if you're looking for a card
just to play titles like that it's going
to be absolutely fine I thought I'd push
the textures to high here uh because
this was fine according to the in-game
graphics menu a good set of figures in
my opinion and I wasn't quite sure what
to expect from Apex borders Gate 3 is
another game that will struggle at
Native resolution 108p with the lowest
settings here well we saw 30 plus FPS
well 31 uh the 1 and. 1% lows did suffer
a little at 15 and7 respectively now
interestingly enabling FSR
1.0 actually performed worse than FSR
2.2 FSR 2.2 also looks a lot better and
it allows us to set the preset to ultra
performance doing so gave us 43 FPS on
average with a one low of 20 30 sorry
and A.1 low of 19 so yeah it was a lot
better um but there will still be
moments of slowdown another older title
GTA 5 with the highest settings the
detail slide is set to five out of 10
Soft shadows and isotropic filtering set
to X8 uh post FX set to normal and FXAA
enabled for an average of 96 I did
notice a few occasional stats I think
this is just an arc card in combination
with an older game these things do
happen happen sometimes let me say
though that the ark drivers have come a
long long way since I first got my hands
on an arc card I remember the a750 I
remember having to use dxvk in a lot of
older games to actually get them running
smoother uh but here things have really
improved I feel and this is another good
example of a game that runs pretty well
on this entry level card the same can
actually be said for Red Dead Redemption
2 to be fair it's a little bit harder to
run of course being newer and Visually
it's a lot better looking but Ultra
textures which I thought was a bit of a
push and it's so Tropic filtering set to
X4 everything else set to lowest the
geometry L maxed out the grass L sets 2
out of 10 and TAA medium gave us an
average of 52 we could have enabled FSR
it would have boosted the frame rate a
little bit um not above 60 though but I
felt that red dead F was absolutely fine
to play between 50 and 60 fps to be fair
um it's entirely up to you though as you
can see from the results this was really
consistent as well as Punk 2077 is best
played at the lowest settings at Native
1080p average 47 FPS with a one set of
39 and a 0.1% low of 13 in order to hit
or almost hit a 60 FPS average we needed
to enable xss set it to Quality mode and
this gave us 59 which I thought was a
really nice Improvement this also
improved the percentile lows as well
coming in at 48 and 46 so improved the
consistency too and pretty much
transformed the game it was still
playable at Native 1080p in my opinion
but this made things a lot better
without much of a visual sacrifice hell
I two at the lowest settings will run at
37 FPS with analing on trouble is this
is a fast-paced shooter so you're going
to want a higher frame rate than this
this is why I switched once again um to
upscaling I set the render scale mode to
Quality for an average of 60 this time
around and as you can see our percental
lows were improved yet again without
much of a sacrifice in terms of visual
degradation so this is definitely the
way to play in my opinion I finalized
them with fortnite at 1080p with a low
preset 100% 3D res and TAA I was running
in dx12 mode because it was a little bit
smoother here for 83 frames per second
39 was at 1% low and 18 was that. 1%
figure so playable but the odd stutter
here and there now aside from gaming the
A310 like other art cards is great for
video editing thanks to av1 encoding
it's a pleasure to use with the Vinci
resolve for example um we have to focus
on gaming though because that is
primarily what we're all about here on
this channel and as you've just seen it
can be a mixed bag it is an entry-level
card after all and in some cases I think
it did fairly well but I'll have some
comparisons to other lower-end offerings
soon to see how it Stacks up in the
grand scheme of things these cards
definitely do better with older games
than they used to that's for sure I
think the drivers have come such a long
way and that is essential especially
with lower-end Hardware too thanks for
watching let me know your thoughts down
below and hopefully I'll see you all in
the next one